front processors are orders of magnitude larger in Cubit size gates are far improved and we have introduced methods
of reducing or mitigating errors intrinsic to the quantum systems even while we push forward to create fault
tolerant Quant quantum computers now you and anyone else can use one of these numerous IBM Quantum processors that are
hosted on the cloud almost all of which are the newest latest and greatest systems with over 100
cubits but isn't just the size of the processors that is important this is only one metric that we care about and
that makes sense right if we have more cubits that's obviously better provided that increasing the number of cubits
doesn't degrade performance however this isn't always is the case we need more good quality cubits that don't interfere
with one another through cross talk when we don't want them to how the cubits are connected to one another is also something important to keep in mind in
superc conducting circuits it's a challenge to figure out how to best physically connect the cubits another hugely important metric
is two Cubit gate Fidelity Gates that run on single cubits are not as prone to airor two Cubit gates are the much
bigger area of concern and usually one of the go-to metrics that we look for to see how performance is improving over
time two cbid gates are crucial to get right because they are responsible for creating entanglement between the cubits
which is one of the physics phenomena that gives quantum computers their power lastly we look for Speed and efficiency
we need to make sure that the time spent running a program on the quantum chip is executed as quickly and as efficiently
as possible we refer to these three metrics together as scale quality and
speed all of them are vital to improve performance now I want to show you some quick plots to back up what I've been
saying about how the technology itself really is evolving quite rapidly the cubic count itself is the easiest to
understand I think and IBM has published a road map of where we hope to be in the next few years in terms of Cubit count
and processor size for 2024 when we're filming this video we are right on track with our processor herin and Condor next
quality this plot shows the median entangling gate error rate for IBM Quantum processors over time keep in
mind that this is a log scale so while the progress looks vaguely linear it's actually much more rapid than that
lastly we have speed this graph shows the progress of a metric that we call kops which stands for circuit layer
operations per second crucially kops encapsulates both the time it takes to run circuits and the required real and
neartime classical compute basically kops is a measure of how quickly our processors can run specific circuits in
series acting as a me measure of holistic system speed and incorporating Quantum and classical
Computing right now at the time of recording IBM is the only Quantum cloud provider that is providing access to 100
plus Cubit machines as I mentioned a few slides ago 100 cubits or right around there is where classical simulation
begins to totally fail so large scale jobs being run on these machines often have no classical equivalent it isn't
possible there is some nuance and some tips and tricks you can play to simulate some parts of a circuit and then other
parts separately but in general we know that right around this number is where quantum computers can begin to do things that classical computers just can't so
IBM decided that giving access to these larger devices was super important for the wider Community because anything
being done on smaller devices is classically simulatable and so it can't lead to Quantum Advantage the 100 Cubit
devices we have now are still flawed and they're still noisy so we need to be smart about how we R run jobs and
circuits on them naively just writing our circuit and pressing shift enter probably isn't going to lead to anything
spectacular but again there are tips and tricks that we can Implement and best practices we can follow to squeeze even
more performance out of these devices which will hopefully lead to Quantum Advantage sooner even while we continue
to work and build up our fa fault tolerant machines as well this plot shows the simulation cost
or the amount of time it takes to solve a problem on classical computers and quantum computers equipped with error
mitigation and error correction so the classical computation line scales exponentially as the circuit complexity
grows for simple circuits down here that doesn't matter matter but it's obviously bad as the complexity grows because this
makes the simulation cost very expensive very quickly air mitigation scales better so when the complexity of the
circuit grows this is where we want to be we are currently here with classical methods and Quantum methods sort of on
par with one another for some applications and error correction might be the most preferable and scales really
nicely we're just not there yet in the meantime we will continue to focus on error mitigation and getting to this
area of quantum utility as soon as possible and by making use of several error mitigation schemes which we will
learn about in this series we aim to find application areas that can make use of quantum utility very soon and that is
really what the heart of this course is we have these machines we think they're capable of doing some really interesting
research so how do we use them in this last section of the episode let's briefly discuss application areas for
practical Quantum Computing there are three main branches that we think we're most excited to explore and find avenues for Quantum
utility the first is simulating nature this has to do with simulating molecular or Atomic interactions and this is
really important for areas of material science and chemistry and for reasons we discussed earlier we think quantum
computers are going to be a lot better at this than their classical computer counterparts next is search and
optimization the main algorithm of Interest here is called qaoa a hybrid classical Quantum algorithm qaoa uses a
classical computer to train and find Optimal parameters for a Quantum circuit and we'll hopefully be able to do this a
lot more efficiently than either computer could alone lastly we have mathematics and processing data with structure quantum
computers are really good at finding structure in messy data where you or I or a typical computer might not see
anything Quantum machine learning holds promise in this area and we aim to use this for tasks such as feature
extraction and pattern recognition it really is a very exciting time for those of us that work in the
field of quantum Computing for the first time in history we can begin to explore a region of computing that lies Beyond
classical Computing those of you watching this might possibly play a role similar to the early pioneers of
computing and they had no conception of what was to follow t J Watson of IBM even famously said he thought there